today's video is sponsored by omnia pillow
and we'll be reviewing the best and worst
multivitamins that you take but first let me tell
you about my sponsor sleep and glow company with
beauty pillow omnia so you guys know i am really
particular about my bedtime routine because
if every little thing isn't perfect and in its
place it's gonna be a bad night i'm picky about
temperature my weighted blanket and my pillow
so much so that i always bring my own with me
wherever i go so i was recently sent this omnia
pillow which was developed by orthopedists and
cosmetologists and i am officially sold its unique
patented design helps to support an optimal sleep
position and it uses memory foam to perfectly
adjust to the shape of your face neck and
shoulders and because it cradles your face rather
than just like lets your head sink into it it
prevents your skin from compressing and twisting
as you sleep now i try not to be vain i honestly
have not had a cosmetic procedure in my life and
the internet tells me all the time that that's a
parent but would i like it if my skin looked like
it did before i had kids without paying for crazy
expensive creams or botox why yes yes i would so a
pillow that will last me five years that can help
prevent wrinkling and puffiness and keep me cool
and comfortable as i sleep definitely feels like a
good investment to me so if you want to try omnia
for yourself check out the link in the description
and use my promo code abbysharp10 for 10 off of
your order you can also check out my disclaimer
in the description and on screen including a
reminder that the information here is really
general and it's very important that you speak to
a health care provider before starting or stopping
a supplement regimen vitamins and minerals
are not benign so please do not be taking them
half-hazardly without knowing about your unique
needs okay so first of all let's talk briefly
about the whole multivitamin world and answer
everyone's burning question does everyone need
to be taking a multivitamin well let's talk about
this according to the world health organization
more than 2 billion people in the world have a
micronutrient deficiency so usually iron calcium
vitamin a b and c research suggests that consuming
adequate nutrients through food is associated
with a reduced risk of death but consuming those
same nutrients from supplements doesn't seem to
have the same effect one analysis of
the research involving 450 000 people
actually found that multivitamins did not reduce
the risk of heart disease or cancer in the general
population now of course it is hard to know if
the type of people who are taking multivitamins
regularly generally have poor quality diets and
therefore it all evens out but i digress another
concern that also complicates this research is
that supplements like multivitamins are notorious
for significant variations between claimed content
and actual content besides the obvious problem of
not getting what you think you're getting which
we will speak to in more detail very soon it
also makes it difficult to evaluate whether any
supplement is improving health if it's unknown how
much of a vitamin the consumer is actually taking
the other general drawback with multivitamins
is that you're getting a generalized bundle of
nutrients that may be more or less than what you
uniquely need so if you were to be working with a
dietitian or a naturopath or your doctor on this
we would probably want to carefully analyze your
diet and or blood work to determine your precise
individual nutrient needs in other words there is
no one size fits all prescription for supplements
because it's going to be highly dependent on
your diet life stage metabolism and health
status and finally also worth noting that some
nutrients are better consumed with food and others
without and you really don't have an option
to optimize absorption when everything is
taken at once in one pill so if you were to go to
a dietitian or at least if you were to come see me
i wouldn't be giving out blanket prescriptions
for multivitamins for everyone i would want
to look at the individual needs of the
client to determine what is best for them
having said that i fully appreciate that
not everyone has the budget or time to see
a nutrition professional about their unique needs
and i also get that even if you do see a dietician
you might not have the bandwidth or budget to fuss
over taking like a bunch of individual vitamins
and pills a truly effective supplement routine
often takes commitment so monetary and time
and a lot of folks are just not at that stage of
readiness to commit to like a handful of pills
multiple times a day there are also people who are
more likely to benefit from taking a multivitamin
so folks who are pregnant or nursing people with
severely limited diets or elderly populations for
whom getting variety and quantity in the diet can
be a challenge so i believe there is definitely a
place for a multivitamin but it's not necessary
for everyone but first a quick rundown on what
to look for when choosing a multivitamin so
first of all let's talk about bioavailability
and absorption bioavailability is the amount of
a nutrient that is absorbed in the intestines to
be available for biological activity in your body
for supplements this isn't just the amount that's
absorbed into the bloodstream but also how much
of the nutrient is used by the body or stored for
future use the absorption of some nutrients can be
enhanced by other nutrients or food so for example
the fat soluble nutrients can be absorbed better
with foods that contain fat and iron becomes more
bioavailable with the addition of vitamin c there
are also certain forms of vitamins that are more
bioavailable absorbable or just generally higher
quality because they're a more active format so
for example i like to choose methylated folate and
b12 because they're the active form and a large
percentage of the population cannot efficiently
convert folic acid now i'm not going to get into
detail on all of these but some of my preferential
forms of various vitamins can be found on screen
right here next let's discuss quantity underages
and overages now a lot of multivitamins go way
overboard on quantities because they're based on
outdated daily value standards from 1968 which
was since updated in 2016. and generally speaking
most consumers think higher amounts of everything
is just better value but for the general
population i try to avoid vitamins that contain
excessive amounts that are beyond the ul aka
the tolerable upper intake level for nutrients
particularly the fat soluble ones like vitamin
a e and k where there is an increased risk for
toxicity and adverse effects there's generally a
bit more flexibility for water-soluble vitamins
because we do have regulatory mechanisms for them
but that also means that in most cases megadoses
aren't beneficial either so if you
see a multivitamin advertised as being
high potency with excessive nutrient quantities
you might want to take a much closer look because
more is not necessarily better and more is not
necessarily better when it comes to the number
and volume of vitamins in a supplement either
some manufacturers pad their formulas with massive
laundry lists of vitamins most of which are in
such small quantities they're more there for show
than actual function we call this window dressing
personally i would rather go for a supplement with
fewer nutrients focusing more on the ones
that i actually need rather than a smorgasbord
of every vitamin and nutrient under the sun
especially because the more vitamins in a
supplement the more room for something to go wrong
or to interact with something else you're taking
next let's discuss quality so there's
a few things to think about here
and a lot of this is really more preference than
anything as i already briefly mentioned that some
forms of certain vitamins may be better quality
by nature of being better absorbed bioavailable
or more active but other considerations
are whether or not the vitamins contain
added sugars artificial sweeteners and food dyes
for folks who are sensitive to things like food
coloring or certain sugar alcohols like i
am i once took a bunch of sugar-free gummy
vitamins before bed and i couldn't figure
out why i was up all night in horrible pain
until i read the label and i saw holy sh yeah i
just unknowingly ate a ton of xylitol and that
stuff doesn't sit well for me but speaking of
gummies i definitely think they have their place
particularly for folks who really struggle to take
a pill or for kiddos who just won't but it's worth
me pointing out that gummies are notoriously
hard to manufacture well it's often hard to
measure exactly how much of a nutrient is in the
vitamin as in some cases the vitamins are simply
like sprayed onto the candy base not to mention
the vitamins are also more likely to degrade
so often manufacturers will add more than what's
listed knowing some fit might not be usable
so it's just hard to know what you're getting
and how much now third let's quickly consider
preferences and needs so if you're a woman you
might need a supplement with more iron and calcium
and that might rule out most gummies on the market
since iron's metallic flavor usually derails a lot
of kind of great taste claims now if you're vegan
you might want more vitamin b12 omega-3s calcium
and vitamin d and also would one of course make
sure that the vitamin forms in the supplement are
vegan as well and if you just cannot stomach
taking a big horse pill like we talked about
you might want some sort of soft alternative
generally speaking chewables or soft gel capsules
are better quality than gummies but of course this
isn't a rule and there are higher quality gummies
out there too and we'll talk more about that in a
moment and finally if you're a busy person whose
supplement routine doesn't run their life you
might want to consider the recommendations of
the manufacturer so do you need to take two pills
three times a day with food or is it one and done
deal whenever you remember these are important
considerations because there is no point in
buying a supplement if you can't remember to take
it finally and maybe most importantly is to look
for an option that is third party tested there
is always a risk of contamination or overages
and underages with supplements like vitamins as
i discussed in my video on supplements right here
vitamins are not well regulated and
therefore you aren't always getting what you
think you're getting this is particularly an
issue with multivitamins because there isn't
just one vitamin that they're sourcing there are
multiple touch points where things can potentially
go wrong this is why it's more important than
ever that when choosing a vitamin you're looking
for one that is third party tested you can look
for the usp seal which is a federal certification
program for establishing supplement standards
or check a third-party testing website like
labdoor.com i also subscribed to consumerlab.com
who did a comprehensive analysis and report
and shockingly of the 27 multivitamins they
tested 44 of them either contained lower
or higher amounts of the nutrients that they
cleaned or took longer than permitted to
disintegrate in solution which would denote a poor
absorption rate also almost all the gummy vitamins
they tested were problematic so yeah all right so
now that you have a good solid basis upon which to
evaluate your supplements let me give you my
brief analysis of the vitamins that you most
frequently asked me about i'm just gonna jump into
this quick and dirty style so this video hopefully
isn't an hour long also a heads up that for easy
comparison's sake the vitamins we analyzed were
for the women's formulations when available and
the prices were listed in the usd prices that i
found at the time of this recording so first let's
discuss those that fall under the category of
regular tablets so i couldn't find much
information on kirkland's women's formula so i'm
going to discuss their general daily multivitamin
here but it's convenient at one tablet a day with
around 100 of your needs for most of the vitamins
without going over the upper limit they are
however often found in lower quality or inactive
forms but kirkland is usp verified lab door tested
and also tested by consumerlab.com and while
they met all lab doors purity standards they did
find significant variations in label claims for a
number of the nutrients especially for folic acid
so that may be a concern particularly for women
of childbearing age but at two dollars a month
it is a very affordable option so i give
it a green light now mega food has a ton of
different formulations for women which
while a bit overwhelming for a newbie
it could make it easier to find the best
formulation for you if you have some direction
now mega foods main differential selling point
is that the nutrients are coming from whole foods
which sounds great but it's important to note that
this is still not equivalent to actual whole foods
not to mention you can market a supplement as
being natural or whole food-based as long as
it contains just 10 percent of its nutrients from
plant-based ingredients and this is true for mega
food so the usp regulated vitamin or mineral is
delivered in the food but not exclusively from
food anyways marketing aside they don't always use
the active or best quality form of some nutrients
and i also find that a lot of their formulations
contain a lot of random herbs that you
probably don't need or want but if you have some
professional direction on what is safe to take for
you personally i do like that it's just one pill
a day there aren't major overages in quantities
and of course it is third party tested so
ultimately it passes my test now mediherb
does not have a product that is labeled explicitly
as a multivitamin but the closest thing i could
find was a product they call herbivityl which was
intended for healthy aging but you asked me about
it so here we are it's basically a blend of herbs
like japanese knotweed root extract milk thistle
korean ginseng grapeseed extract etc with
only six percent of your daily needs of
calcium you're also supposed to take one tablet
three to four times daily who the hell has time
for that uh plus it's pretty pricey and it
does not appear to be third party tested so
this is getting a hard pass from me now hum
products are actually founded and formulated by
redshirt dietitians and they're tested for
safety by a third party so that's great
they don't have a women's formula specifically but
at one capsule per day the dosage for their multi
is pretty convenient and while many of the
nutrients were close to 100 of your needs levels
for vitamin d and calcium are a little bit low and
it also seems strange to me that there's over 800
of your needs for vitamin b1 random they also
didn't use the best quality or active forms of a
lot of nutrients which is often what happens when
you pack a ton of vitamins into one pill i also
don't like that a lot of their other products have
questionable names and purposes like flatter me
for a flatter stomach and counter cravings
to boost metabolism both of which are not
evidence-based of course but i'm not reviewing the
branding and marketing as a whole so i guess for
10 a month they get an approval stamp now nature's
made vitamin levels are mostly either at or around
100 and the overages for a few of the vitamins
don't appear to be significant or beyond the ul
a lot of the nutrients aren't in the best quality
active form but the serving size is also just one
tablet a day so it is relatively convenient now
labdoor did rate it highly for product purity
but low for label accuracy with vitamin c
measuring at nearly half of its stated claim
but this product is usp certified it's
relatively inexpensive and underages like this
in a multivitamin are unfortunately pretty common
so these do get a green light from me now deva or
diva i'm not really sure how you say it is labeled
as a vegan multivitamin and mineral supplement
now although many of the vitamins are at
or close to 100 almost all the b vitamins
have huge overages in the case of vitamin b3 or
niacin it's well over the tolerable upper level
those who supplement with too much niacin have
reported itchy and red skin all over their body
headaches other rashes and dizziness this product
is also really low in calcium something that
those who eat a vegan diet should probably be more
mindful of and i got a d grading on labdor.com
it actually rated fine for purity standards
but it rated poorly for projected efficacy
and they found significant label claim
variants on 26 key vitamins particularly
vitamin a so i would probably pass on deva now cvs
is another inexpensive option most of the vitamins
in cvs's women's blend are very close to 100 of
your daily needs though some key ones like calcium
and potassium are very low it is convenient to
take at just one capsule a day it's third-party
tested and it's super inexpensive at just two
dollars and fifty cents per month having said that
a lot of the vitamins are in lower quality less
optimal forms but if you're on a budget cvs gets a
green light from me now jamison is a canadian
brand that's marketed as helping you meet 100
of your body's daily vitamin needs with only one
capsule per day and while most of the vitamins are
listed at or close to 100 of your needs some of
the minerals like calcium and iron are completely
absent they also don't use the active bioavailable
forms of some nutrients but it is third party
tested and just six dollars a month so it does
get my stamp of approval now nature's bounties
women's multivitamin has no alarming overages or
unbridges plus a convenient dosage of just one
tablet per day most of the vitamins are not the
best quality or active forms but it is third party
tested usp certified inexpensive and compliant
with gmp supplement quality standards so you
can add them to your list to try now one a day is
another classic drugstore brand with most of the
major nutrients found at or close to 100 of your
daily needs you also only have to take one a day
as the name implies but a lot of the vitamins
aren't in the most absorbable high quality form
it also uses ferrous fumarate iron which while
very well absorbed isn't always as well tolerated
so something to keep in mind if you have a
sensitive tummy having said that it is third
party tested inexpensive and therefore gets
our stamp of approval okay so moving on from
the harder tablets let's talk about soft gels
or soft capsule options so ritual is a favorite
for me because it's third party tested and usp
approved it contains the bioavailable forms of
its nutrients like methylated b12 and folate and
you only need two vegan soft pills a day now it
doesn't have vitamin a c or calcium and only has
seven percent of your magnesium needs for the day
so it might not be appropriate if those
are important to you but it's actually
their belief that less is more and considering
that i personally and professionally agree that
it's better to get what you need rather
than a lot of what you don't i actually
really like this minimalist approach so ritual
gets my stamp of approval now another popular
millennial product the care of multivitamin
is a little bit lower in some of the major
nutrients of concern like calcium vitamin a and e
but they do use higher quality forms of nutrients
and chelated iron for sensitive tummies plus they
are third party tested in nsf and gmp certified
facilities for safety and purity so this gets a
thumbs up from me now similar to the mega food
brand weber's multivitamin contains a lot of
superfood and herb blends like wheatgrass juice
powder and green tea polyphenols and turmeric
and ginger extract and alfalfa juice powder etc
most of which i see as window dressing seeing
as i can't imagine what getting 15 milligrams
of cruciferous vegetables is really gonna
do also in a lot of cases it seems it's
at the expense of the actual vitamins since
a lot of the key nutrients like calcium and
iron come up short it also doesn't contain the
methylated active versions of folate and b12
but it is manufactured in a gmp facility and
it's third party tested so this still gets a
green light from me now nfh doesn't have a women's
formula just the general multi so we looked at
that not only is nfh validated by third party labs
but they are also an eqp gold partner meaning it
meets the emerson quality gold program standards
for quality assessment however things get a little
bit messy when we look into the actual ingredients
the values for many of the b vitamins are well
over the recommended intake with b12 coming in at
over 40 000 percent of your daily needs and folate
is over 400 which for some folks could actually be
dangerous there's also significant underages for a
number of important vitamins like vitamin e and
d and you have to take three capsules every day
so this is a brand that i actually really love for
individual vitamins but maybe wouldn't be my first
choice for a multivitamin but it still ultimately
gets the green light now cytomatrix's dosage is
two capsules twice per day which for some folks
just maybe isn't very realistic or convenient
i do like to see that most of the nutrients like
b6 and b12 are available in their bioavailable
forms but some key nutrients like calcium iron
and most notably d are a bit low this company also
appears to be gmp compliant and third party tested
and there aren't hugely significant overages or
underages in this one so ultimately it gets a
thumbs up from me now vivo life doesn't have
a women's formula but their vegan multi-nutrient
and mineral supplement is recommended to be taken
at one capsule twice daily which again is
not necessarily super convenient most of the
vitamins are provided close to 100 of your needs
but it is quite low in key nutrients like vitamin
k calcium and iron and there's no folate which
would probably be important for a lot of women
but it is third-party tested for heavy metals
and other contaminants and it is fully vegan
so ultimately it has my stamp of approval now
canned prev's multi offers most of its nutrients
at or close to 100 of your needs and uses the
active forms of b12 and folate which is great
but my biggest criticism with the can
prev is that you're supposed to take it
three times a day i don't know i find two times
a day is already pretty cumbersome so to remember
a midday pill just might not happen for most
people but can prep products are manufactured at
gmp facilities and are third party tested so these
do get the green light from me next up is natural
factors women's multivitamin which is dosed at
three capsules per day now while most of the
nutrients are supplied in appropriate quantities
a lot of the vitamins are not in their highest
quality active forms now my biggest concern with
this one is that it's padded with a ton of herbs
enzymes and extracts with little to no evidence
to support them which i think most people would
probably see is like a good thing but as i
already mentioned it just adds more room for air
and adverse interactions in my books having said
that it is third party tested so while it wouldn't
be my first choice it's still likely a credible
safe choice so it does get the green light from
me now is another popular three soft gel per day
option a lot of the b vitamins are in pretty high
quantities and the folate isn't methylated for
those who are looking for that there's also a
bunch of window dressings like evening primrose
oil cranberry concentrate grape seed extract etc
and in the case of something like evening primrose
oil you would probably want to make sure that it
was appropriate for you having said that now is
certified by a bunch of regulatory bodies and it's
relatively inexpensive so it does get the green
light from me and finally garden of life packs a
ton of different vitamins most of which are found
in higher quality active form but the folate is
not methylated which you know i would like to
see the issue is that you're supposed to take
four capsules total two times a day which might be
a lot for us to well swallow that's what she said
don't you dare there's also a lot of enzymes and
probiotics and other antioxidants a lot of which
are not evidence-based and you're paying for all
of those bells and whistles at 45 45.99 per month
they are however heavily tested and audited so
despite being one of the most expensive options
they ultimately get a green light now lastly we
obviously have to talk about every influencer's
favorite way to get their vitamins gummies i mean
they are pretty delicious but they are not to be
taken as candy now ollie's women's multivitamins
come in the form of two gummies per day which
supplies two grams of added sugar some of their
nutrients are pretty low most notably calcium
at eight percent of your needs and a lot of the
vitamins are presented in lower quality forms
most problematically while the ali website
says that all products are produced in
gmp facilities and are audited by the fda and
third party certifiers ollie has failed testing
by consumer lab in the past for having huge
overages that were not listed on the label
this is pretty common with gummy vitamins which
i already mentioned are difficult to control and
manufacture but i do have greater concerns with
overages than underages in these cases they're
also not vegetarian as the gummies contain gelatin
so just a heads up for all my plant-based friends
but there are no artificial flavors or colors
which i personally like finally the brand offers
a wide range of blends that aren't necessarily
well supported by the literature like a blend for
better sex drive and sensation called lovin libido
and a happy hoo-ha blend for vaginal ph balance so
yeah they technically get a green light
for safety but they wouldn't be my first
choice now the serving size for smartypants
multivitamin gummy is six gummies daily which
admittedly feels like a lot it also provides
six grams of added sugar now the b vitamins
a k and calcium are pretty low or non-existent
which again is not uncommon in a gummy vitamin
and they're not vegetarian as they contain gelatin
but they are third party tested and they use
higher quality active forms of vitamins in there
so well gummies are typically not my first pick
they definitely get the green light from me now
with two gummies per day vita fusion supplies
three grams of added sugar and while most of
the nutrients clock in at 100 of your needs
it is low in calcium and lacks vitamin k and
iron a lot of the vitamins are also lower in
quality or not in active forms but this brand is
certified by third parties and gmps so ultimately
they get the green light now herbalance unisex
gummy multivitamin is recommended to take two
capsules two times per day which again not the
most convenient now while most of the vitamins
are close to 100 of your needs it is a little
low in vitamin d with no iron or calcium and
they also don't use methylated folate now unlike
most gummy vitamins these ones are sugar-free but
they contain a variety of artificial sweeteners
and sugar alcohols that maybe are not digested so
well for people who are sensitive to fodmaps
that being said they are third party tested
and i've tried them and they do taste pretty good
so for gummies i would give this a green light
there was a lot of information there for you to
swallow that's what she said or he said or chew i
guess your choice but to recap most multivitamins
are produced by reputable companies and are third
party tested but as reports from places like
consumerlab and labdor.com suggest it doesn't
mean they're always perfect ultimately which
multivitamin you choose is going to come down to
your unique needs your budget and accessibility
so if you think you need a multivitamin i hope
this gives you some information for choosing the
right option for you if you're wondering how your
vitamins stack up you can check out labdoor.com
and read the manufacturer's website very carefully
for information on their testing procedures and
on that note that is all that i have for you
guys today thanks again to omnia for sponsoring
this video if you liked it be sure to give it
the thumbs up leave me a comment below about
what you'd like to see here for you next
subscribe to the channel and i will
see you next time on abby's kitchen
bye